[Music]
i was really interested in this article
because recently we already know that
there was a billion dollar lottery
situation oh my god i couldn't play
because we live in vegas what the [ __ ]
you guys ripped me
me
off
what do you mean i bought tickets wow
uh like 20 bucks worth wait on the
border though
oh no no no cause i was i was back here
especially
we got scanned there's nevadans bro you
could get it no the casinos own us bro
the casinos don't want you playing that
lotto [ __ ] because then you won't play
the casino games so you can't do it as a
nevadan you have to go to the border bro
you have to drive all the way the [ __ ]
oh no but if you have you if you bought
a ticket you still you could win right
julia sorry i just said i just said
yeah yeah you have to cross the border
get the ticket you know there's that
california lottery store right there by
buffalo bills yeah so it's not far it's
like 30 minutes it's 45 minutes for me
oh you lit wait no you live 15 minutes
north of me pal that's 45 minutes away
from getting a billion dollars no it's a
billion dollars if i win you see how
much in taxes they took
no it was like okay so i think it was
like 1.2 something and and how much they
won
they took 800 mil
so they were left with 400 mil
that's what happens when you take it all
at once you get more money if you take
it over 20 years or something like that
but everyone says take it out yeah
everybody should yeah
they're just paying themselves yeah it
doesn't matter because i'm rebuilding
right now okay look i got
one two two bam look at all those ones
six seven eight nine dude don't forget
don't floss it all at once man 20 40 60
80. oh my wife took my hundos
my wife took my [ __ ] hundos those
[ __ ] shits well done wife wait did
she take it or did you just spend it oh
they take your hundos
so that's just proof that these are this
is all gambling by the way revenue so
like super bowl he called the rebels you
boys
that's this money that's still there
and
i did the uh nba finals
on the warriors
thank you very much there it is thank
you that's about seven i'm on my way to
the bill but it's gonna take a while i
think whenever you guys bet i'm betting
the opposite
again so actually uh this was fun
because there's this dude who had won
the lotto back in the day he actually
had one you know uh this was in the uk
one nine point seven million pounds
but he explains how he went bankrupt in
eight years that's what always happened
a lot occurred
every time that sounds like it lasted a
pretty good amount everyone blows
through their money because they can't
handle it i think the average is
actually like seven years yeah and then
they blow through it all blow all of it
how do you blow a billion dollars i
wonder how you're gonna blow 400 million
though because how would you do it joe
you're the expert 400 million
buy a failing business that costs 399
million
i'll buy a [ __ ] i don't know feels
like enron seems like a really great
growth opportunity now is this i'm
buying toys r us
dude i'm buying toys r us sears i'm
buying kb toy store kb
soup plantation yes
that's a gold bundle somebody bring it
back
elon musk where are you at when we need
you
elsewhere the chicken noodle soup i
think it was just getting everything all
at the same time dude just get progreso
a little hint a little tip
no it's not watery enough no way
honestly my guilty pleasure there was a
[ __ ] muffins oh with the whip butter
oh
the muffins you need pizza there
you know what i did though i'd rather go
to hometown buffet you also have [ __ ]
terrible's coffee all the time so like i
i don't trust your judgment that's good
chevron coffee at terribles did you ever
make your loaded
your own loaded baked potato there
absolutely
and then you get your chili and you pour
it all over the cheese and all that [ __ ]
and finish it all with the [ __ ]
sundance
beautiful serve was about the only
viable thing there yeah you can't just
do this at golden corral i've got to go
to call the crowd let's go to the crowd
team
golden corral all the time
chicken or ribs or something i can't
just be eating the [ __ ] but you guys
don't remember that video of golden
corral where they put all the meat
outside in the sun when the health
inspector was i loved that video maybe
defrost what does that what does that do
i was starving watching that
vitamin d bruh that's how i defrost me i
love golden corral man so guess what
happens to hunters meet okay taking
forever this uh this dude's name is
michael carroll
uh he won in november 2002
uh when he bought a one pound ticket and
it was his first time playing whoa
just 19 years old when he won big oh
that's one dollar he didn't even have a
bank account to deposit his winnings in
that's some charlie in a chocolate
factory [ __ ] gave his friends
million dollars each eight years is a
long time for a 19 year old no here's
the thing though this is this is what
happens to people like him right he also
ended up becoming a target for people
who wanted a slice of his money and were
willing to use violence together
see that's what they do it's like
vanilla ice he
woke up at home one day to find his five
dogs had been killed
and blackmailers threatening his family
while on another occasion men with
shotguns arrived at his home
in the uk he could have [ __ ] bought a
little army with that money oh [ __ ] get
some ira guys mm-hmm well why are the
doggos
they did nothing wrong right they
definitely did nothing wrong why do they
target him when it's like well maybe he
lives in a bad neighborhood or whatever
because there's a lot of people out
there that actually make that kind on an
annual and they could be targeted too
yeah maybe his bad neighborhood as for
what he actually wants i'm glad i'm
always publicizing how broke i am and
how much i lose all the time because
then i'll never be a target it's so
smart that's smart you can't get you
can't rob from a person who has nothing
right yeah it's super good to always put
that out there even though you have all
that money and you're safe at your house
in vegas nope i don't have a house he
doesn't even have a safe
so
um as for what he actually wanted to
spend his money on one of the first
things michael did with his 9.7 million
pounds
was he gave a million quid each to his
mom his aunt and his sister and they
blew it all he set up a four million a
pound investment bond while he also
invested another million into the
rangers his favorite football club okay
but then like he said he bought 150 000
pounds in gold
so these seem like pretty reasons
yeah
among his purchases with his lot of
winnings were 325 000 pound mansion
which sounds fairly cheap right
getting on uh he he bought a whole fleet
of new cars including a new range rover
two bmw m3s a bmw z4 that's right that's
where they get you you need that many
in uk but not one security guy not one
security guy he also revealed that he
was spending about two thousand pounds a
day on just cocaine
oh
this is where it gets squirrely
while also spent a day about a thousand
pounds a day on prostitutes
that's expensive how do you get up there
how do you get up there with prostitutes
that's a lot how do you how do you
[ __ ] go through two thousand pounds
of cocaine a day
because it's probably for everyone he's
hanging with all the prostitutes
he's putting the bill the coke bill him
and the prosecutor partner my own wife
is exhausting dude it's exhausting not
when you're cooked up
he's 19 too so he was probably like a
version didn't have a bank account and
he's like wait so i could have this like
real life porno [ __ ] like i don't have
to jack off and he was like oh my god
and he's at the age when all enjoyment
feels like it's never going to end
that's true when you're old you already
know how things are finished yeah true
2010 his spending had blown through his
lotto winnings and he reapplied for his
old job as a bin man or trash man i
believe
since going bankrupt he found new work
in scotland as a coleman and reported to
get back together with his ex-wife he
previously said he doesn't regret
winning the lotteries it brought him
years of fun for a pound though he did
seem unhappy with the z4 describing it
as shitty
wow now his scale is all [ __ ]
up
because i heard that that causes more
stress like
when you go up to a certain point and
then you crash down from it it's more
stressful than already being at a low
point especially if you're young yeah
that's the saddest part man
yeah there's nothing but the [ __ ]
horror stories with people who win the
lost plus that now that whole thing is
it's such a strong part of his identity
forever because it's not like he did
some other remarkable thing prior he's
probably just known as the [ __ ] guy
who blew the lotto window at it
because he's 19. the guy who went horn
and lost i wonder how many yeah he's
[ __ ] though because that's that's
crazy well i don't know every day how
much did you pay to eat that hooker's
[ __ ]
what how much did you get babe
wind it depends on that one
we know we didn't get paid
at which time and if we talk about
america it's probably about a hundred
ish if we're talking about overseas
hundreds about 50 euros
um ish about the same if you convert it
yeah
no now it's one for one now yeah so
eating a hooker's [ __ ] probably a
hundred euros yeah i should have got
paid actually i [ __ ] what did what
was i thinking you're a bad businessman
negotiating you're just taking chances
yeah
you should have bought a plane [ __ ]
dca that stuff dude yeah you got it he's
here you know maybe i should have worked
in non-profit in charity instead of
trying to do business because i'm i'm
always losing [ __ ] i can't do charity
giving it away i still think you're a
winner joe if that makes any
defined winner is it a guy who eats
hooker [ __ ] then i guess he found a
ringer he's still even [ __ ] though am i
right yeah yeah
that's pretty sick
right
wait wait is this the same one
in amsterdam no no i didn't eat her out
no alhambra i'll hamburger
[Music]
you